joining me now is Ohio Congressman Jim
Jordan ranking member of House Judiciary
Committee and Molly Hemingway Fox News
contributor and editor-in-chief of the
Federalist Congressman it's uh nice that
uh President Biden did finally reach out
to Governor DeSantis but he also uh
declined
to cancel a fundraiser tonight to help
more you know obviously Democrats get
elected governor which just seemed I
don't know seemed to off I want to
politicize this but it does seem off
tonight yeah and if president Trump did
that you can imagine what the left would
say and you're exactly right leadership
matters we had great leadership under
President Trump we're seeing great
leadership from the governor I think the
governor's at what he says already have
a 40 000 line line workers on on standby
he's got National Guard on standby they
got planes ready to go I think you talk
about air land and see ready to help the
residents and families of his district
and he's already set up a way to raise
money for the families who we're all
praying for who are going to be impacted
by this and as you point out what's Joe
Biden doing raising money for himself
and for Democrats the same people have
given us all the problems we see it
unfold across our country whether it's
crime whether it's border whether it's
inflation over the last 20 months so
leadership matters and we're seeing a
stark contrast between real leadership
that we had under President Trump and
this governor and what we now have with
President Biden and Molly a CNN reporter
tweeted today as DeSantis prepares
Floridians for Ian he's urging residents
to heed advice from the same local
leaders he suggested they ignore during
covid and praising a federal agency that
he previously alleged withheld Aid to
the state because Biden was playing
politics
Malia hurricanes and covid the same
thing here if you understand the
difference between hurricanes and covid
then congratulations you're smarter than
a CNN reporter also but you know just
there really had been so many problems
with Public Health Management
particularly at the federal level and
Florida local emergency experts are
unfortunately seasoned in this type of
catastrophe they are giving good advice
it is wise to recommend that people
listen to those local emergency leaders
and just more than that this is not the
time to be playing these kinds of games
I get that reporters hate Ron DeSantis
they hate that he's very effective at
pushing back against them and other
people on the left but the reason why
he's so popular isn't just because he
pushes back on them and and other
craziness and left it's because he is a
very good administrator of his State you
know when you go down there people
whether they're Democrat Republican they
Praise Him for how he handled how he
kept the state open during covid for how
he's friendly to businesses like they
like his policies it's not just because
he's this conservative well and
government is supposed to work for the
people not be conspiring against the
people right and and we see that
happening in various States across the
country but Florida really is a shining
example along with Texas and Tennessee
and South Dakota Iowa the Run well
they're states that are actually run
well yeah it's we the people not we the
government we the people elect folks to
make decisions not the bureaucrats like
fauci who think he's smarter than
everyone else when speaking of covet so
yeah that's exactly right and that's
what again great leaders understand that
our constitution starts with those three
words we the people they get that
Governor DeSantis president Trump they
get it unfortunately today's left which
one's our federal government they don't
they think power is all about the
government and the bureaucracy and doing
what they want to do versus what we the
people elected folks to do well it I was
talking to someone the other day and she
said to me not really political person
like old college friend and she said I I
I start to think like I feel like I'm
the enemy in my own country like I feel
like I'm an adversary to to the people
that we vote for or that who are
supposed to serve us regardless of
political party and I said you know
that's a really good way of putting like
we're the enemy like no we're the people
we're not the anime don't treat us like
the anime Molly while um the hurricane
of course is just slamming Florida John
Kerry thought it was the perfect time to
tout Biden on the climate
the inflation reduction act will be uh
an accelerator of action it has really
serious money as incentive for the
deployment of Renewables for the
manufacturer of the Nobles for the
deployment of electric vehicles the
infrastructure for it this is a job
creator
Molly there is this wide-held conspiracy
theory on the left that man-made climate
change is the cause of hurricanes which
is just absurd on its face we've had
hurricanes ever since the dawn of
creation they average you know I think
the average number of hurricanes from
1851 to 1860 was 19 that was the same
number that we had between 2011 and
2020. there are more people living in
coastal regions that does mean that
costs go up when hurricanes hit but
there's just no evidence for this theory
that people keep holding and then also
the number of years even if you believed
all of sort of the propaganda that comes
with this legislation the number of
decades it would take for it to bear
fruit in terms of any of this is you
know it would not have mattered when
they passed this but Congressman before
we let you go on this issue of insurance
in these flood zones this is a huge
issue playing out in all coastal areas
of the country a lot of insurance
companies just pulling out all together
their losses have been so big there's
like we can't stay in business here what
is the answer on that because the
federal flood insurance care covers very
little yeah a little bit but not a lot
of the values of this home so what
happened I mean look I would I would
defer to the experts on the financial
services committee what what needs to
happen uh but I'm always reluctant to
embrace any type of big government
solution certainly big federal
government solution we typically screw
it up as evidenced by this inflation
reduction act which we know actually is
is driving up the cost of goods and
services and and actually contributing
to the inflation problem so but I'll
leave it to the guys on the financial
services uh committee we have some sharp
people there who I think will uh will be
able to address it yeah it's gonna it's
gonna hit Florida hard after this uh
Molly and Congressman Jordan thank you
so much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else